all right everyone thank you so much for
making it this long to the end of our
three-day epoch of data science journeys
so here we have our closing notes and
because you know Ian and I are a big
deal these days these were delegated out
so let's see how it goes right so
excellent we've not seen these slides
they are written for us we have many
monkeys the monkeys right the things and
yes and we blame the monkeys when the
monkey is bad it is a pilot edition of
course that is why we are doing it and
me hello hello I'm a great presenter
slides written to mimic our natural
speaking stuff because I love having to
read multiple sauces charming goofy I'll
come across this incredible urge mixing
thank you so much for attending planet
London well let me many thickness us
many things Oh a huge proportion of the
meter quarter it was exactly one of over
3,200 members are part of this meetup
global movement and global community
there's pride 80 meetups all over the
world all over the world sword out
conference held in london third year in
a row gets better every year every year
well the work actually know what kind of
liber8 I'm not out to yeah sorry what
happens in the world anything data
scientist data engineer statisticians
let's just get together
about community right yes ramp up my
ramble time right and Travis opened this
morning by the lovely keynote Thank You
Travis and talked about community and
the necessity of strong community please
put up your hand if you have ever spoken
at a meetup committed to a core project
done some documentation given a talk
than any of those community things put
your hand up okay everyone clap these
people that's right everybody else now
put up your hand please remember that
you are using things written by other
people for your commercial benefit and
it'll be really good if you contribute
it back so think about think about
filing your first bug do documentation
contributing to a project giving a talk
any of those things just do any of those
also we've got other people to write the
documentation contribute to the code
pull request things of that nature this
is what makes our community great ramble
over that one this there we go all right
and excellent my other pet topic Python
tu veux surprise and three they'll be
choosing Python 3 yeah yes chef
excellent who's using Python two guys
that's kind of half-and-half that's
getting better every year don't forget
you've got a couple of years then Python
2 is turned off so every line of code
you write in Python 2 will have to be
forcibly Mike related to Python 3 so
you're might as well stop writing Python
2 and write Python so yeah i get--oh
there's lots of things that are in the
way and that's hard but you're going to
have to translate that at some point
that's a waste of time stop wasting your
time just go to Python 3 that's a good
idea yeah okay second railroad yeah you
granddad writes Python 2
I told her what I'm expansion Emlyn clay
yeah and Oswald I'm the coach oh this
event along with Emily Indian ah yeah
and I see where that was going um we
aren't the only ones yeah you'd think
you'd think that we set the whole thing
up which is certainly not true we just
do the onstage bit oh so we had thanks
to you all oh yeah yeah all our main
living Kennedy's yeah that is toy we are
convincing that is though thank you very
much all of our basic attendees were you
this is the go right yeah all of you
thank you very there's a buying a ticket
now off you go grab a nectar tee shot on
your way out there are extra ones right
they make excellent dining where you
know they're they provide certain amount
of insulation if you have a kettle and
the kettle's not particularly good tisha
partners kids right i mean colleagues
people you work with that maybe XL and l
so if your kids XXL you've got bigger
problems right
are three key note speakers so and less
Fraser gave us a really nice physics
talk yesterday morning Tatiana gave us a
a journey into becoming a data scientist
I know inspired a lot of people and
Traverse this morning gave us a a
wonderful overview as to how Python is
moving into the whole big Java world so
a big round of applause base alright are
over sixty percent of our chat or over
60 thank you thank you to our over 60
tutorial and main session presenters
please they raise your hands to the room
and you're a speaker or teacher put your
hand up there must be more of you than
that come surely right Stan of Sanatana
place oh yes no prob i'll set up and up
teachers and speaker stand up these are
all these all the people who helped me
and this and this bit about slides it
doesn't enter you guys yet we want the
code give it to repositories like
throwing your excuses it doesn't run you
get it done you must all know the
message by now in the slack channel good
a hash slide inside hash slides there's
a Google sheet on the Google tree it's
got your name and a blank spot in the
blank spot you put your github link and
your blog post and any other [ __ ]
you've got about yourself your speaker
deck let's do it we need that for the
publication of the videos that's fine
right o our lovely team so Kelvin Celia
and up and up Steve Priya Ruby Slav
easel here and Steve's not here today
there we go we started all of this in
November I think so it's been going on
for a lot of months please thank our
team here and
a fantastic volunteers that's mark I
been the room politics yep but Rafael
Michael a very last-minute save it yeah
okay present and absent please thank
them very much our terrific sponsors our
sponsors and you've heard me go on
pushing you all to go and talk to our
sponsors because they're here to
understand what you want to be doing
yeah anja hire you as well it's great
good conversations to be had so thank
you to continuum yep they were only
there the reasons why we're all here
they push all this at beginning they're
the reason we're doing all of this
definitely thank continuum and then
channel 4 here with their hiring there
we go that there's patter you can't miss
pad are you in darvas man in the room I
think oh they might fail they failed a
bit earlier on okay I'm in that case I'm
the semi Indaba representative list and
who sponsored the deep learning track
yeah and behind ya and provide a whole
bunch of speakers as well and petticoat
with a CD clinic and the PhD training
seminars a flourless was right serenata
flowers we just gotta check saying we'd
like to sponsor pie later we'd love to
know if anyone is a representative
serenata flowers and how they use Python
we'd love to know and thank them very
much for their we be right about that
squeak week we're going to admit we
thought it and possibly would have been
a bit of fraud or a scam or something
but like they've you know there must be
a very very good reason behind it it
must be a very reason no no we're
ignorant right now I'd like to be
Lessing what is the big data problem in
flowers flower delivery service I mean
there's some good logistics are you
saying a rush niche delivery time
capgemini photo/matt you spoke at the
end yet cheers me and we always it's for
picking up part the bar tabs choice to
hear tom tom tom tom tom tom i'm still
thinking you from my hangover thank you
very much
very particular special thanks to
Bloomberg Alex you get all the praise
because you're probably the only bloom
burger in the room and are there we go
you both get it share it so thank you
very much to bloom both the catering
organizing space the security it all
comes glottis to the conference so the
money that would otherwise be spent
renting a space instead goes to numb
focus to sponsor all those projects and
this gives us all the toys that we need
in our day jobs in our academic work so
thank you very much the Bloomberg for
making this possible finally choice of
adjectives sir ly ly the salubrious
people's in this from none focus yeah
they kind of they sit in the background
and are doing all of the engine of
driving all the bits that happen in the
background there's a ton of admin with
doing these things not only that where
they deliver this on an international
scale so they have to deal with us late
night cause early morning calls and the
rest of it yeah it just it honestly
wouldn't be possible with that kind of
coordination behind it they do such an
amazing job at a certain point open
source grows up and becomes very mature
and order to steward things they don't
fall apart or rats or get dependent on
just one person committing to the repo
and having it so they can just continue
on and become Enterprise worthy tools
like most people here are working with
both in their day job part of businesses
and have those things in production it's
not really possible without this kind of
organization behind it to make us have a
nice stable base to work from say thank
you very very much numb focus
and always oh sorry oh good lead it yeah
I just told you or none focuses yeah we
know sorry then I'll see Chomp Chomp you
can hear it gained now charmingly numb
focus is the open source organization
that organizes the global PI data
movements thanks to the folks from non
focus whose hard work makes this and
every pie later a success at Gina
Helfrich Lynn Brubaker and Savannah
Mikado we have to we speak to these
people all the time I've never met them
in person whether you're an enormous
amount of work and an extra special
thanks cuz y'all make it all possible
here yeah Liam yeah you guys stop you
hiding lately have you thought have you
thought of running for president because
to be at the moment the race is pretty
darn bad I think you'd make it I'd vote
for you and take a moment on your way
out to frankly after cashew she really
is the one who brings all the bits
together for this and every other
conference so just thankful as you go
past she'll appreciate it embarrassing
for sure I have no idea it's like
nothing we've got the stage oh yeah
we're not done we wanna know you will
know I'm insatiable let us know if you
want to volunteer so we yeah we will
never turn down a willing volunteer we
have all these things that get done like
as you saute the volunteers who did the
comparing in the rooms they're sort of
the running around that's getting the
speaker's their stuff hanging out the
microphones and things of that nature we
also have the meetup that goes on every
month the things of that nature like
justice with none focus like stabilize
things we also want the meetup for
itself to be completely stabilized and
not dependent on just a couple people
holding the thing up so if you want to
be part of that it's really good fun we
meet up regularly and if you like what
you have here then we basically do this
every month and then a big one every
year so you know come and be part of it
there's the sign-up list on the
registration desk and put your email in
and then we'll ask you would you like to
be involved no commitment just indicate
you're interested um okay oh yeah we got
great feedback this event here's some
international feedback we want to read
aloud today it's still bad about this
gone bad data is the best event to meet
other praticing data scientists everyone
here is actual user of the duel this is
my favorite conference I'm croydon board
I look forward to this event every year
the keynotes were lovely opening max
next year no you will put on a great
show I'm super super glad that I
traveled from Amsterdam to be here yes
yes fight at the London Fog sufficient
potato Berlin is in two weeks Phi Beta
London is discount code to use besides I
don't be babe we don't have a picked up
better'n friend our weekend Oh acts in a
random the whole sentence is one rat not
as random element of it right okay yeah
that right okay thank you so much
and now and now the thing evil waited
for you probably missed the last train
home where your fairy or you playing the
lightning tortures worry Leslie primate
for it leaping in a leaping into action
yep good leaping right lovely HCM wait
that one out that one back to so you win
Florian of court as everyone knows
you've got five minutes by lightning
talks this year of course if you are
over running in time you are going to be
sorted by a Crouch ninja so it's time
people otherwise it's about to get messy
flowing how's it going this is a live
demo of course it is not this again so
where we had a live demo from Florian
you know that will be 80 in Palo win and
it went fine ok stop vector if you got
trauma yeah you're good five-minute
timer ok hold right off in five minutes
are we good yeah right so I guess I
guess apart from Python 3 the constant
that was in use all the time in this
conference was the notebook and
everyone's using it and I hope you also
using git and you may have come across
this annoying issue that if you version
control notebooks then you get all this
messy output so here I have some random
notebook that just yeah
with some ticket data from some people's
for every company and if I version
control this so I'm setting up to get
repos here one on the left on the right
and there's this utility called envy
strip out which you can install in a git
repo and whenever you save something or
like you state a file in gate then it
will automatically strip the output from
the git repo as you all know notebooks
are stored in as a JSON file so if we
now look what we have now so I've added
the repo file to get and if we look at
what has been stationed get we see that
on the one without Envy strip out on the
left when I when I save the notebook
then we can see on the left hand side
without Envy strip out we have a whole
bunch of output varies on the right hand
side we don't have that they were the
same I am in the same directory yeah so
I've set it up
the demo gods are not not happy
and now if we change this to run some
other take care for instance change this
to google
and save the notebook
then you see on the left hand side we
now have all this noise because the
image is stored as a base64 encoded
string in the notebook and of course
because I've reruns themselves the
execution count has changed whereas on
the right hand side the same directory
same file on disk in my diff I only see
the four characters that I changed
because I've only changed the apple
ticker logo to the to the Google ticker
and this is the only thing I really care
about right so if you want to use this
it's on github just search for envy
strip out or it's also on pi PI so you
can just pip install and B Strep out and
then call in in your notebook Envy strip
or destash install and what it actually
does is it sets up in your git config it
sets up this filter this is
automatically run when you do an
operation such as staging or committing
and it also sets up a get attribute that
this filter is to be run for any
notebook file with this IP ynb extension
so install yourself some Envy strip out
and I get rid of your hassles with birth
control in your notebook this is built
on top of and be convert which Thomas
introduced in the session before and I
think I'm out of time so I'll hand over
to the next speaker this is a require
git hub repo which might be interest for
package maintainer so he's not
maintaining packages are not wanting to
do I'm sorry for your wasted five
minutes so first of all are a bit of a
background so I'm part of the austere pi
project and community which is a a
community effort to develop a single
core package library of pastrami Python
and it contains a core package and
elated packages very similar to the side
by ecosystem and the one important thing
that most developers are scientists
astronomers and it's not our day job to
do this
so for this to ease up the effort the
core package provides some kind of
infrastructure help to to have ovulated
package maintainer to do the job it
includes documentation tools testing
framework whole package layout and
templates will see I testing and now
it's the motivation for the CI helpers
which is a bunch of shell script is that
we are having a very complex see I
matrix all kinds of versions for our
upstream dependences and sometimes they
are broken and sometimes so this all
started then the Minicon de Paz change
and when I wanted to make sure all
packages were working the CI had to go
to 230 repositories to just change one
bomb variable so that's why we started
the CI helpers as I said it's a
collection of shell scripts it's not to
be used as a sub model because we then
be going back to the same issue that
going to every package and updated but
you do the cloning at the install part
of your CI set up at the moment we have
travis an affair so just you you clone
the repository and just saw salt the
shell scripts and what it does it sets
up Minicon the environment and it
installs the dependencies you can
control wats I dependencies what are
they their versions by environment
variables like condo dependencies or
what's not in Conda or any of the
conduct channel setting people
dependences you can also set versions
for different packages and it also
understands that
have stable and perilous for numpy and a
stop I which means that you don't have
to hardwire that you want to test lean
on pi 1 point 11 or whatever it always
goes to the latest stable and what we do
here is very important for our
affiliated packages that we if there is
some problem a blocker upstream of a
body imag got laid or whatever then then
we limit the version number of that so
the oscillating maintain errs don't have
to care about that that the
documentation building is broken because
of some upstream plane the one important
thing is that that's the link for the
report so please if you find it useful
just play with it and they are working
examples you go to any of the main
packages in a stop I and echo system
like 40 I supply itself just look at the
Travis Wyman or the up layer by Amell
it's I think it's pretty obvious there
is also a very extended readme file sooo
yeah use it if you find it useful hi
there I just thought I'd use this
opportunity to get a quick bit of
publicity in for a meetup I organized
with wojtek and circa shits the London
cable meet up there's quite a few people
I've seen who have been at various
events of ours as well so but if those
you haven't joined up please do i'll try
and give you a quick summary of what the
kind of things that we do and some of
the events we've got coming up over the
next month in the main we do two types
of events we do hackathons and dojos
hack the next hackathon is going to be
in the fourth of june it's going to be
in rise London in Whitechapel usually
call central working very the way it's
set up is we've got a big room like this
one we put a lot of tables in there we
said at each table gets given a
different Carol contest also but I
should probably started who here is
unaware of keggle okay Cagle is a
website which hosts data competitions so
various companies host their date set
something then say we want to solve this
contest for instance there are as a
competition the moment where there's
photos and say can you recognize which
one of these drivers is distracted or
there's expedia the moment I say given
custom information can you work out what
kind of hotel they are going to book in
future as well and there's usually cash
prizes for those as well so I sort of
got around a few cable contests and I
want to sort of meet other people who
are doing them as well and I thought a
meetup was up to a great way of actually
meeting other people so as I said where
we actually do the hackathons and the
dojos we basically put several tables
outs we say there's a different
competition each table go there speak to
others meet other people I've met some
really fantastic people and loads of
great ideas and techniques from them as
well the hackathon these that's on a
Saturday it starts at about half-past
ten because we only get a boat in a
weekend really we finish at about five
o'clock with a few beers as well the
dojos are usually held they actually
always held at a dick whaty which is
just up by more gate as well so they're
normally the one last two weekends of
the month they normally go quite quickly
but an idea unless you signed up you
hear about them the main thing I want to
plug is we've got sort of special
one-off events on May the 17th that code
node which is just around the corner
here we've got two talks to the guys who
met up at the meetup did really well in
a competition reaching they go in the
top 2% if anybody was aware of the
rosslyn competition where you had to
forecast sales in 900 pharmacies in
Germany and they did very well in that
so he one of guys going to give us a
talk about that as well and how he found
it we've also got to talk a guy who
helped until about a few weeks ago was
the number one kegger in the world he's
now number two so I'm not too sure if
you wasn't there anymore that's Mario's
Mickey ladies and that's right we
actually open this up yesterday and
we've actually been quite surprised we
were already actually filled up however
we were given the option to actually
expand the room so if you do sign up the
meet up and you do want to come along
put yourself on the waitlist and
hopefully in the next two or three days
we will have we will get like a bigger
verbal more chairs put in there as well
so that's all every want to say about
the things if everybody also chat with
them and how they work please speak to
me afterwards as well
and yes thank you very much and also
thankful in evidence to the pilots
temperatures and from the title well
what to do when you have jupiter
notebooks in indeed so I the good part
is that i don't think i will make it 25
minutes so it's going to be very quick
but well this is my typical research
setup I have not lots of joy and that
looks just for curiosity I checked how
many had created in the last days and
this is rough me I sure I don't think I
think most of them are really created by
me because I should have filtered out
most of the downloaded ones so I have
more or less 500 not books to learn for
research yeah and if you create some
random data and then you come it and
then you change the data and then your
Elodie you get ugly stuff and not even
interactive is actually yes and wow so I
started asking around how do you people
do and I've had this question I propose
my answer and i'm sure there is a better
as for some other than I didn't see it
and it's exactly the same thing which
means it's a very good things to do so
maybe he's it's better but to use it
anyway and that's it on github that's
after using that all right you already
know it but since you already knew
everything about this I will propose two
things which I think are missing and if
i understand correctly are missing from
the env strip too and the first is the
we don't necessarily hate output that is
we don't want to commit it but it's
confidently if you change branch and you
come back usually like to have your
absolute back maybe because it took
three days of computation to have it now
it's technically not too difficult but
slightly more difficult than that to
keep it you have to store it somewhere
you have to map it some way to the
source in a moment in which to commit
this didn't sign on Ash so contribution
welcome I plan to do it so it's not a
huge obstacle from a technical point of
view but didn't find the time and oh the
other thing is at least mine doesn't
work with chief get gift git diff to
if anybody of you have suggestions on
why and how I mean I know why because
diff tool compares with the real file so
if anybody has suggested how to fix it
I'm interested also maybe i will close
the project after today ok and yes I
have said I was a technology enthusiast
up until now and mostly because I had a
pen on there and this pen was very
essential to my demonstration so I
cannot show you this now but I can I
have a backup luckily and I've been
fiddling around with my pen about seven
years ago and I started analyzing these
pen strokes and I found these feature
points here where you can see where the
stroke turns and where the stroke goes
into a corner so i made this algorithm
for pen strokes and what i did with
these points is i would geometrically
overlay these two stored points in a
database where I could find get a true
false result for each pen stroke to
determine whether this feature is
contained within a database stroke or
not so I went on I did this prototype
for like six months I thought maybe I
was going to be able to sell it well
many illusions many pounds spent later
about four years ago I had a different
idea why not well if I could dance
across a time-based series function
graph what if I could turn my function
graph into something like this
up here and once i get to this point i
could get all these feature points here
like the turns and the corners and i
could do the same thing with my database
and get a true false result for every
impulse in a time-based series so yeah
just to finish off this day with with a
little dance maybe I can illustrate this
so this is my time based series this is
my delta according to my sampling rate
and now in order to get this to resemble
a stroke I would have to analyze all the
pieces of the function graph where the
function graph is rising and where the
function graph is falling so as long as
the function graph is rising I would if
I can illustrate this with a dance I
would turn to the left it's rising right
now I have my direction of the previous
vector so I take my next vector and I do
is step in the same direction so this is
what it ends up is it can be so this is
how its constructed basically you have
all these little steps here and then I
go to this one here it almost is like
the pen stroke we've seen four and
yes finally we end up here so so you
will probably ask me why not just use a
function graph so I'm going to
illustrate this like let's say you have
a high frequency and a low frequency and
I'm going to illustrate this with a
function graph now so just wait until I
walk off the stage then my talk will be
finished so I start over here and I do
it with a function where fright I well
sort of we have a short frequency right
so I do this short frequency I could
keep on going and now there's a long
frequency so pretty small frequency to
illustrate this and I put right that's
what you you're going to see in your
data with the second derivative is how i
turn my foot should be or if you can I
hope you can follow
I do the same thing with with my graph
here with my pen stroke preps okay so
what actually happens to belong
frequency is that actually accumulates
middle parts and pieces put my website
address for I before you start your next
top we've got a huge machine though oh
okay there we go github spec pose put
into the slack channel okay perfect spec
pose spec clothes on github so thank you
fesi oh and then let's take that out
that's so you're near parenthesis right
and then you know index my array you've
just discovered a new dance for my
friends Thomas yeah I was more notebook
stuff right more notebook stuff but
first so lightning talks phones enough
of a challenge i decided to try and fit
two completely separate topics into one
lightning jewelry [ __ ] when it starts
now almost so topic number one is the
super mini lightning talk show name
check about one minute why am i showing
to a cemetery this is the tomb of the
Reverend Thomas Bayes ascend bayesian
statistics it's just round the corner
from here so if you are a big fan of
Bayesian statistics then you are in
exactly the right place to pay your
respects to the last resting place of
Bayes the person who invented it it's in
bond hill cemetery and which is about
five minutes walk away so
um and now to the the real lightning
talk that I put down on the sheet which
just in case you're not bored of it is
yet more how to store notebooks and get
and and the punch line is I've got three
separate ways so this is number one is
recombined content manager so this is
when you save a notebook it will save it
into two files the I PI and B file
without the outputs and the I PI and
video of something else file which has
the outputs in when you when you open
the notebook it will try to recombine
them so it will use the clean copy that
you stored in version control as the
master and it will try to like match
outputs back to that and stick them in
we are actually going to do something a
bit like this sort of integrally to the
Jupiter project so we're going to have
something will call a companion file
which will be like a zip file let's get
saved next to the notebook and you can
either like exclude that from get or you
can check in to get and treat it like
her like a binary image or some things
you don't try to merge it and we'll
configure what you can put in their way
number 2 mb dime notebook def and merge
this is an experimental tool that one of
mins coworkers in Oslo is developing
they've apparently just hired another
person and to help with this so this is
something that you can plug in to get
and with complete notebooks in version
control it will do like nicer diffs of
them and provide better ways to merge
them i think it's going to be like a web
interface for merging it's still very
new and experimental but there this is
like in active development there is
there are people sort of working very
much on this and way number three is the
like super crazy experimental hack and
which is that ok so the problem was
throwing notebooks and get fundamentally
is that notebooks are structured json
data get doesn't know about structured
json data it only knows about folders
and txt files which are like
series of lines however you can turn a
structured Jason object into struck a
structure made up of directories and
text files so where it says sample test
that I pay and B dot exploded /eu ID
that that is a reference to a notebook
and then a cell with in that notebook
and you can see I have cell metadata as
Jason the cell source code as a Python
file and outputs as the appropriate
types of file and that's all in a
directory which represents a notebook
and this comes with this tool NV explode
which can turn a regular notebook into
this directory and then the directory
back into the regular notebook thank you
everyone this lightning talk is just a
talk and it probably will be very fast
my background is Python in the computing
in the finance sector sorry let me first
explain the title medium data what do I
mean by that well probably data that's
getting to big data it depends with it's
on your laptop on your server or
whatever i don't mean anywhere near big
data I just mean data that's getting too
big if that makes sense to a real-time
analysis and companies such as Bloomberg
in the financial sector pump out a lot
of data stock prices currencies rate etc
now do a lot of on the fly calculations
but also a lot of batch process
protesting most batteries take about
eight hours purely because that's the
time from when you given when you take
your end of day prices to when you have
to deliver them in the morning so you
speed them up and up and up and as
volumes increased functionality
increases you have to do various
performance tuning and all data comes
out very good very valuable and then
your boss says right that's great great
but I wanted real time so what do you do
I've been thinking about this and I'm
developing a little system that's based
on a dag
direct a typical graph messaging books
and distributed computing dad's a lot of
people have talked them this weekend
Luigi it's a little bit different too so
that direct a circle graph in the fact
it's of computational graph and the
input whenever an input changes then
that triggers on the next calculation in
the in the in the graph rather than
waiting for the mall to happen before it
triggers so the night the beauty of the
dag is that only parts of the
calculation tree that need to get
calculated get recalculated every time
there's a change to the input so this
speeds things up a lot it also is is
very easy to make it distributed I've
been using docker containers and so each
single process is doing one calculation
it listens to the message boss takes in
the input and then spits out the output
onto the message bush as well also using
docker containers and single process is
to listen the results from the message
bus and then produce graphs in chart to
see the results again the beauty of this
is it scales very very well for as your
volume with your number of trades your
complexity of scenarios or or your
portfolio's or your instruments grows so
and thank you for listening and if
anybody else is interested do come to me
and have a chat afterwards thank
so I don't have a lot for you to have a
lot to present for you in fact I tried
to put together this demo during the
other lightning talks so I hope that it
works before I get into that I would
like to say that I think this has been
an amazing event somehow this event gets
better and better each year I had a lot
of fun i hope that you did as well i
hope that you take a second on your way
out to thank all of the organizers for
this event to especially thank ian and
emmalin and to thank leah silent from
numb focus the people who really make
this event possible so i was up late
last night and i thought you know i have
all these notebooks that i want to
commit to my git repository wait what's
going on I wasn't paying attention to
the line to talk to somebody I do this
one okay I'll say something else I had
this before I don't think you've ever
seen this I'm kind of every time I do
something kind of wild it takes about
one or two conferences before I get
tired of it so i'm actually already
tired of this but maybe this is new for
you so i have a python 3 installed so
python 350 I haven't touched it at all I
just installed and I installed it when I
built in an install that when I was
sitting in the chair there this isn't it
this isn't like a special thing that
I've set up and I pip install the module
I don't want a pip install the module on
stage because if the Wi-Fi is a little
bit flaky then we'll get tied up in that
so to python 350 and I pip install the
module that I wrote called our watch and
those of you who are C programmers or
C++ programmers are very familiar with
what read watches are it's a
functionality that makes a lot of sense
when you're debugging i C or C++ program
you have the ability to set read watches
on pieces of memory so that every time
that piece of memory is read it triggers
a break point and that's a great thing
to do because sometimes you have memory
mapped i/o or for other reasons you want
to be able to well as a data scientist
this is also actually kind of useful
because sometimes you have very large
data flows and you have millions of data
items and then one of those times is
kind of snagging the flow like there's
one malformed piece of data somewhere
along the way that just doesn't it just
blows up and you don't know what
functions looking at our what part of
your pipeline what part of your
processing pipeline is it's falling over
as a result of that done it you don't
have adequate logging or it could be for
many different reasons and there may be
many steps where they're mutating the
data or there may be even multiple
concurrent steps that are mutating the
data so it's very difficult to track
down what you'd like to be able to do is
say here's a piece of memory or a Python
object every time somebody looks at that
Python object just let me have a call
back and then you could figure out every
single place that your data flow either
passes through that object or something
like that so i created this module
called our watch and when you import the
module it actually adds two things to
the SIS module it adds sis not get our
watch and set our watch and let's look
at the help text forget our watch it's
actually not very interesting the help
text says it returns the target set with
sis not set our watch nothing too
interesting there and if i look at set
our watch it sent read watches for the
targets now if you look at this it tells
you that the targets should be a mapping
of object ids two functions that's
pretty simple so i'll show you a really
simple example i'll just create a
function that takes two arguments a
frame in an object and all it does is it
says I saw that object at that frame in
a Python program the object at the frame
by the way if you're doing live demos
always use short variable names because
it really helps on the typing and I'll
just return the object then i'll create
an object X and I'll just set an hour
watch on the ID of X and F and then
every time my system looks at X I get a
call back that's pretty nice and if I
had a function G that took some variable
X and returned to x squared and I looked
at X and I looked at the function called
on X you can see it shows up twice 14
when I pass it to the function in 14
when the function actually looked at the
argument so now I can kind of tell if
I'm passing an argument into a function
is it ever actually being looked at that
could also be very useful now there's
another that's something really
interesting that you might be able to
immediately see from this oh I'm going
over time don't worry
I give a call back so couldn't I just do
this
look I have Sam boxing and Python
because now every time you look at the
object it raises a runtimeerror you can
never look at the object and it's
interesting because people always talk
about Sam boxing and Python as being
something that's very difficult and this
may not be the perfect technique but you
could do kind of interesting things here
like you could set an R watch on the OS
module so people couldn't look at the OS
module and you might think oh maybe
they'll get around that and they'll
they'll find some way to import it so
just set it on the OS string so they
can't even construct a string what the
word Oh acid it but that's me but i want
to show you and this is the last piece
of it and this is actually really wild
nobody nobody ever notices this or ask
this but here's what the oh one neat
thing about python and one neat thing
about the kind of python my writers I
like to write it very pythonic Lee so
you saw that I gave it a dictionary I'll
give me a second why don't I give it a
default [ __ ] instead of a dictionary
so instead so what I'll do is I'll set
in our watch with a default [ __ ] that
just triggers on everything so now I
can't look at anything if I actually did
this then here I'll just do a simple one
this is a little tricky to do and sore
object there and now everything is going
to be triggering this is a default
dictionary now it's going to kind of
blow up my program so I'll just I'll
just start this program one more time
import our watch promises imports that
our watch and I'll show you something
really neat I get the object if the
object instance is an integer
everything will be triggered on this
watch who can answer for me x equals 1
what's X equal to what's X equal to who
can get this right wow that's really
smart x is equal to 16 this could really
ruin somebody's day thank you very much
it's been an amazing about thank you
very much James thank you very much
everybody there's one group you've got
to thank the audio team have been
running around with dongles and all sort
of things seem really really awesome
making it work please write if there's
any Lost and Found it'll be in the
cloakroom just around the corner
speakers go into the hash slide channel
don't drop your slides in there go to
the Google sheet and link them in there
please pi day to Berlin the discount
code is still available product of
London two weeks time pi day to Berlin
but hands up panetta Berlin all there's
more of us now excellent great we want a
few more of you coming out ok pi data
London is a discount code and that's it
and no no no and that'll be it yeah all
right thank you very much everybody much
everyone